das hier ist das brandenburger tor
es wurde 1789 gebaut und ist das
wahrzeichen berlins
während der teilung berlins verlief
genau hier die berliner mauer heute noch
erinnern diese steine an den ort wo die
mauer stand das hier ist die russische
botschaft sie befindet sich auch ganz in
der nähe des brandenburger tors
das hier ist das berühmte hotel adlon
das ist eines der bekanntesten hotels in
berlin und in ganz deutschland es wird
auch das inoffizielle gästehaus der
bundesregierung genannt denn sehr viele
staatsgäste übernachten hier
hier haben zum beispiel schon bill
clinton george bush die queen fast alle
chinesischen staats- und regierungschefs
und fast alle oberhäupter der
europäischen staaten übernachtet das
hier ist die französische botschaft sie
befindet sich direkt neben dem
brandenburger tor am pariser platz
das hier ist das holocaust memorial
hier wird der über sechs millionen juden
gedacht die während der ns zeit ermordet
wurden
das hier ist die amerikanische botschaft
in berlin
von hier aus hört der nsa angela merkels
handy ab
dieses gebäude ist der reichstag im
reichstag befindet sich das deutsche
parlament
hier sitzen unsere abgeordneten dieses
gebäude hat eine lange geschichte
es wurde schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert gebaut und schon vor dem
zweiten weltkrieg gab es hier
parlamentssitzungen während des zweiten
weltkriegs und danach also in der zeit
der teilung deutschlands wurde das
parlament hier nicht genutzt aber nach
der wiedervereinigung wurde das gebäude
noch mal renoviert und seit 1999
befindet sich hier der deutsche
bundestag das hier ist das
paul-löbe-haus dort befinden sich die
büros der abgeordneten des bundestages
hier halten oft viele schwarze autos
wichtige politiker steigen hier ein und
aus in diesem ganzen areal ist noch vor
wenigen jahren also vor 1990 fast nichts
passiert in der nähe hier verlief die
berliner mauer
und hier in dieser zone gab es fast
keine aktivitäten erst nach 1990 wurden
hier viele gebäude im neuen
regierungsviertel gebaut unter anderem
auch das kanzleramt da gehen wir jetzt
hin
das hier ist das kanzleramt
hier arbeiten angela merkel und viele
andere personen
das kanzleramt ist acht mal so groß wie
das weiße haus es gibt sehr viele büros
ihr aber auch wohnräume angela merkel
wohnt hier allerdings nicht sie hat eine
private wohnung ganz in der nähe von
hier und das ist auch etwas besonderes
in der deutschen politik die politiker
sind in deutschland meistens nicht so
öffentlich wie in anderen
angela merkels mann ist zum beispiel in
der öffentlichkeit ziemlich unbekannt er
könnte jetzt hierher laufen und die
meisten deutschen würden ihn nicht mal
erkennen dass hier ist die schweizer
botschaft vielleicht erinnert ihr euch
in folge nummer 119 hat manuel die
schweizer botschaft besucht und die
schweizerische botschafterin interviewt
das hier ist der berliner hauptbahnhof
er ist noch ziemlich neu er wurde nach
der wiedervereinigung gebaut und 2006
eröffnet früher im geteilten berlin gab
es nur den bahnhof zoo im westen und den
ostbahnhof im osten
jetzt gibt es in der mitte berlins den
hauptbahnhof
der hauptbahnhof wird jeden tag von
300.000 reisenden besucht
das ist das aktuelle wetter in
deutschland berlin drei grad köln 12
grad sensationell es wird sommer das
hier ist der spreebogen park der
spreebogen park ist ein park an einem
bogen der spree nämlich zwischen dem
hauptbahnhof und dem regierungsviertel
das ist das schloss bellevue
hier arbeitet der deutsche
bundespräsident
unser aktueller präsident heißt frank
walter steinmeier
ihr habt ihn in der folge easy german
180 gesehen
die flagge auf dem dach heißt dass er
gerade in berlin ist das ist der
tiergarten der tiergarten ist ein
riesiger park in der mitte berlins
er erstreckt sich vom schloss bellevue
zum zoologischen garten bis hin zum
brandenburger tor
das war unser video über den
regierungsbezirk in berlin wenn ihr mal
in berlin seit kommt vorbei guckt euch
die orte an
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt
noch weiter deutsch üben mit diesem
video mit easy german werdet einfach ein
mitglied brunsbüttel
dann bekommt ihr übungen zu diesem video
und zu vielen vielen anderen videos auch
interaktive online übungen bei denen ihr
die grammatik und das vokabular noch mal
testen könnt viele liebe grüße und bis
nächste woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]